you ever think you
make viory I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values contag
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm the I'm the
a lot he's got a level of poise okay we
got uh episode number 333 with Jeremy
boring let me properly introduce who
this man is he's he's kind of a big deal
in his world Jeremy boring is the
co-founder and co-ceo of the daily wire
and the host of popular podcast daily
wire backstage featuring Ben Shapiro
Andrew claven and Michael nolles boring
passes and political media including uh
includes founding uh along with Shapiro
the conservative news and commentary
website truth VA Revolt uh serving as
executive director of friends of Abe a
fellowship of conservative working in
the entertainment industry and founding
declaration entertainment where he wrote
and directed the feature film The ayal a
modern Western set against the
lawlessness of America Southern border
he's got a movie that just they they
gave the release the the trailer a
couple days ago it's got 18 1920 million
views already called lady Ballers you
got it we'll watch this preview here
together it's absolutely hilarious but
here's the thing as well he's like a
dynamic type of guy you know somebody
pissed him off with razor so he goes and
starts his own Razor Company ger uh
Jeremy's razors and the commercial I've
never used a Razer but the commercial is
fantastic I can tell you that here's the
the website to Jeremy's Razer it was
phenomenal and for some of you guys that
are nuts or you're nutless he's also got
a choc company that offers you those
with nuts and those who are nutless jimy
great to have you on a podcast great to
be here thanks for having me on yes I'm
want to open up with a very simple
question because I think it's a
challenge a lot of people are dealing
with and maybe you can help figure this
out especially with the recent bit of a
drama which will get that knocked out of
the way I think it's a good story to
talk about early on so you know there's
this saying you cannot serve both God
and money at the same time have you
figured out a way to do it because
billions of people are struggling with
this yeah well I think that the problem
with Fame wealth and power is that
they're highly corrosive you know if you
if you attain any measure of any one of
them uh it it tends to separate you in
some way from your humanity and so it's
a it's a constant challenge it's
obviously a challenge that predates any
of us and will be here long after one of
the things that I've noticed is the
later in life those things come the
better the reason is because you're more
of a fully formed person before you come
into those sort of Temptations and so
you know you see guys I've known a lot
of them over the years who who achieve
incredible success very very ear early
in life and and they're really arrested
in that moment you know it's it's a it's
a trauma to become successful I mean you
don't want to you don't want to gripe
about it you know they're worst traumas
to have but it's still very traumatic
when people stop telling you the truth
people start telling you the things that
you want to hear people always need
something from you they're always
hopeful that they'll get something from
you so you know I'm not one to disagree
with Christ and say that there uh is
some way to serve God uh and money what
I would say instead is that um probably
what we should do is pursue success and
consider that distinct from serving
money you know there are there's a
constant Temptation where money is
involved to make it the focus of your
life I try to hang on very Loosely to my
success I'm not always good at that but
I try to hang on to it very Loosely to
recognize that you know I'm not the
author of all of My Success certainly I
think you can give people a lot of of
good advice about how they might achieve
some success I think there have
obviously been some things in my life
that allowed me to to achieve some of My
Success uh at the same time and anyone
who has success knows this there there
is Fortune there is um Providence there
is some sort of unseen hand that guides
us through life people who made the same
choices that we made people who fac the
same circumstances that we made and end
up with a slightly different or
sometimes radically different outcome so
I don't think it does well to serve
money I don't think it does well to hang
on too tightly to your successes I I'll
give you this and then I'll move on when
you know I I spent 20 years in LA from
the time I was just a kid really where
in the valley I heard you say Valley
where' you live in the valley Studio
City Sherman Oaks my my entire two
decades out
there uh and at one point my wife and I
wanted to buy a house and you know it's
a big deal to buy a house in La
especially when you're uh on the younger
side because houses out there are
incredibly expensive yeah you know I
guess now they're expensive everywhere
but back then it was sort of a unique
thing about the big city and I told my
wife you I think that we have the money
we can make this down payment we'll be
able to service the debt and we didn't
know lot of people who who owned houses
at that time except people who were
friends with who were very very very
successful we were not and my wife said
you know what if we what if something
changes and we lose the house and I said
oh well we'll move back into an
apartment I I don't understand the
question she said yeah but people will
see that we sort of reached and then
it'll be embarrassing that we felt and I
said well I'm not going to be judged by
the people who never moved out of an
apartment if I have to move back into an
apartment like that's just I think that
that's kind of the innate thing that
entrepreneurs have is a a will this to
sort of face the humiliation of failure
M to to see value and virtue in Failure
you know I'm the product of many many
many failures one of my great goals in
life is to make a billion dollar mistake
someday uh I think that failures make us
who we are that that is I think the
difference between people who serve
money and people who understand the
value of money I'm I'm not ashamed to
have some I'm not ashamed to pursue
success but I hang on to it lightly if I
have to move back into an apartment I'll
move back into an apartment I I want to
stay on that but the reason why I asked
that question was because of what uh uh
Candace Owens tweeted out so I wanted to
kind of get right into the uh uh feud
between Candace and and uh uh Ben and it
was pretty public obviously with the
Israel challenge taking place you know
these guys grown back and forth he's got
strong positions where he's at and you
you know she has strong positions where
she's at and Candace is not one that's
going to sit there and be quiet about it
but you know how do you as a CEO of a
company with all this different talent
that He guys have first of all you have
Jordan Peterson with d w okay you got uh
Matt Walsh what is a woman I think he
may have figured out the answer to the
question by the time he was done with
the documentary it was a very
interesting process it was an expensive
journey
to you got Candace Owens okay you got
your business partner but also talent
because he's not the operator you're the
operator Ben Shapiro and you got a few
other guys there as well um but how do
you manage when you have two of the
loudest voices in this sphere going at
each other on on the same team and you
know if you want to leave you can quit
how do you manage all of that yeah well
poorly apparently because it really
spilled over uh into a public dispute
which I think you know obviously we'd
all prefer that that not have happened
in the way that it did but I pay people
to talk for a living I pay people to
have opinions and you're going to
occasionally have conflict when you
allow people a lot of latitude to say
what they believe and you know I think
to Ben's great credit I can't think of
any other Talent who has started a
company that empowers more people uh to
say what they believe without having to
agree with him you know Ben is perhaps
the most famous uh Orthodox Jew in
America and yet he empowers Christians
on his platform to not not just be
Christians and have a platform but to be
very uh forward- facing with their
beliefs on that platform that's you know
that's to Ben's credit Ben allows people
who disagree with him on economics and
allows people who disagree with him on
foreign policy he gives them all very
broad latitude to say the things that
they believe to your point he's not
running the day-to-day operations but
that philosophy of what the daily wire
will be and how it will Empower its
talent to have their own opinions is
something that Ben and and our business
partner Caleb and I you know instilled
in the company from the very beginning
uh and so you know nothing that took
place in this conflict limited anyone's
ability to say the things that they
think when you have very opinionated
people on different sides of an issue
sometimes those flashes are going to
become more front-facing as you say
Candace isn't one to back down Ben's not
one to back down either uh
and so we found ourselves in kind of a a
little bit of an ugly situation and and
it seems like it's calmed down now do do
you when that happens do you immediately
call a meeting and call a zoom and guys
let's just get on the call and try to
Hash this out is that the approach or
you kind of let it fizzle out and you
know have them deal direct with each
other yeah depends on who's involved I
suppose you know some people take
criticism better than others and and
also sometimes you know it's the nature
of conservatives that were somewhat
reactionary and so sometimes going
directly at the problem isn't the best
way in that situation to come to a uh to
come to a consensus you don't want
people to feel like you're boxing them
in you don't want them to feel like
you're trying to force them to back down
when what they do for a living is never
backed down so I think it's you know
it's delicate this one was particularly
delicate uh delicate to manage but you
know I was actually out of the country
you know produc ing a film series that
we're doing called the pin dragon cycle
my business partner Caleb was flying
this one far more directly than I was
yeah he got on the phone with with both
parties and you didn't uh tell them what
they had to do but made some suggestions
about what might be helpful and uh and I
think that they both found their way
back from the brink a little bit
fantastic that's that's good to hear uh
the question I got for you is you know
for someone who's a right brain I get a
feeling you're fully right brain but you
also got left brain you know you seem to
be creative but you're also an operator
how do you as a creative go from a
creative meeting where you're trying to
come up with ideas and you got the
sensitivities of all the creative
quality and you know here's what I think
we should do and what about this and
what about that and what about this and
shut down and what about this and what
about that and what about this and all
of sudden okay so seven steps here's
what we got to do we got to hire this
person call that person get this person
get the production what's the budget
what's how do you manage between I mean
this movie I watched the trailer to
you're doing a phenomenal job acting in
it it's actually it didn't feel like you
it felt like uh I'm watching I don't
know Horrible Bosses and it's you know
just a bunch of actors doing what
they're doing to make you laugh how do
you manage your right brain and the left
brain and know when to compartmentalize
yeah well there is a lot of conflict
between the two and I find that it's
very difficult I can go from operating
in the morning to being creative in in
the afternoon I have a very difficult
time going back the other direction so
some of it is how I structure my day how
I how I approach scheduling meetings and
and the Order of Operations uh you know
at the end of the day being an
entrepreneur being a a writer being a
producer it's really it's really the
same job you're trying to make something
out of nothing so anyone who's quite
often people from my my time in
Hollywood will say I I don't understand
how you went from this to being in
business you know don't you miss the
creative side and I'm like well I've
created hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars of value I've
created hundreds and hundreds of jobs
I've created you know podcasts and
created uh websites and commercials you
know it it is an expression of my
creative self to have built this
business I think anybody involved in
business can probably relate to that
then there are obviously distinctions
you have to be much more practical
obviously when you're operating than
when you're conceptualizing the other
thing is hire great operators you know
in the early days of the company I was
very Hands-On in every aspect of the
operation I think that's probably true
for most people who start something over
time you have to replace yourself and I
think you always have to replace
yourself at the point that you're the
best instead of trying to replace your
you the it's hard to ever learn to
replace yourself in business and the
first mistake that you make is to
actually hire people who only do the
things you're not good at and that's
good in as much as sure you're
eliminating some of the some of your own
deficiencies but your business can't
grow if only replacing the things that
you're bad at you ultimately have to
replace all the things that you're good
at and over time you replace things that
you're good at with people who become
better at those things we have great
operators in our company now our our the
woman who operates our e-commerce
business the Razer company The Chocolate
Company you she's Best in Class As Good
As It Gets our coo John Lewis absolutely
Best in Class As Good As It Gets those
guys have empowered me I think to be
able to put more and more of my time
into these creative efforts but the
creative efforts really aren't wish
fulfillment either you know I've enjoyed
this time making these movies I've
enjoyed being overseas I don't want to
do it again next year I want to find
somebody better than me have them go
replace me in that aspect as well and I
can get back to thinking about what's
next for the business got it so so for
you uh uh let me let me stay on this and
so do you see yourself more as a uh you
specifically because when I when I
listen to you the times that I watch you
you know you're not as much creating
content as the other guys are the other
guys are creating a lot of content
there's a lot more content to see of
them you you're you create content but
it it's it's it comes here and there I
would assume your operating company and
your strategy and all this stuff behind
closed doors everybody has somebody they
they view themselves as do you view
yourself as you said I want one day be
able to make a billion dollar mistake to
make a billion dollar mistake you have
to you have to be 25 billion you know 20
to $50 billion plus upwards close to
even $100 billion to be able to make a
billion mistake can afford and not go
out of business so do you see yourself
more as a Murdoch modern day is that
what you want to be do you see yourself
as one being a Disney Walt Disney do you
see yourself as a Ted Turner uh who who
do you see yourself as and by the way I
don't even know if I'm going to get the
answer to this question you know because
sometimes you have to keep these things
close to yourself but who do you view
yourself as you know it's funny I in all
sincerity I've never asked myself that
question you know there are certainly
people who I see as uh influential in my
life for people who I look up to but but
I've never really tried to model my life
after after anyone you know one of the
I'm sort of radically protestant and I
think that one one component of being a
Protestant uh is that you you don't
fully ever buy that any person is
necessarily uh Superior right you
there's this sort of democratization
that happens in a Protestant mindset
it's not to say that people don't do
better not to say people don't do worse
not to say that people don't have have
skills or talents or even innate
abilities you know IQ bapiro has an IQ I
don't have that's a hard lesson to learn
in life we all think we're the it's easy
to say yeah LeBron James is much taller
than I am he's going to be better at
basketball now that's a copout but
that's a at least it's a copout that we
can all commonly accept very difficult
to ever admit that someone's just
smarter than you and they're not just
smarter than you because they've read
the books they're smarter than you even
if you read the books right they have
they have actual they see patterns you
don't see right they have cap abilities
you don't have uh and so I'm not denying
any of that yeah but I am saying that no
one's no one is fundamentally innately
better so instead I look at people and
think what can I learn you know what can
I what can I model what can't I model uh
and and just try to be my own guy try to
put one foot in front of the other so
who's your enemy do you have an enemy
like do you have at least because Drive
doesn't come naturally Drive is is it
has to be inspired you know uh the three
things that causes somebody to be
hardcore driven in my opinion is that
they've experienced unconditional love
from one person okay could be a mom but
for you to know that that exists okay
and you know you're willing to risk
loving another woman because maybe one
day she's going to love you the way your
mom loved you right or father loved you
number two is unconditional pain from
somebody you love meaning you could
never do anything to win that person
over no matter what you do you can make
Millions you can make millions you can
be strong fight celebrity famous
billions of followers you're never going
to win that person over that approval
you're not going to get you need that
that that element is needed as well and
the last one is to choose the right
enemies you know choose the enemies
wisely that drive the hell out of you
sometimes you choose them sometime they
choose you but for you who would you say
is your enemy and who is daily wire's
enemy well that's interesting you
know I think that I probably fit and I'm
sure that in your experience I've never
contemplated this this in this framework
before but I probably have a little bit
of all three of those aspects of my life
if I were going to identify more
strongly with one it would be the second
one the the desire to be loved from
someone from whom you could not gain the
love
and part of whatever wisdom I've managed
to get and I don't claim much in life is
the realization that that person doesn't
exist that the because the person from
whom you wanted the love obviously
doesn't exist or you would have gained
it so in some ways you've you've taken a
person who does exist and you've
superimposed onto them the person that
you wish existed and that's a real
that's a painful lesson because it tells
you something about yourself that you're
not functioning in reality uh that you
that you don't meet people where they
are that you need something from someone
that they're incapable of giving you um
that even if you could somehow get it
you still wouldn't have it because it
would require fundamentally destroying
the thing that actually exists in favor
of the thing that doesn't but sure I got
enemies too bud you know you want to
tell us a couple of them I would say
that you know some of our ene some of my
enemies have chosen me you know I had
the I went to Hollywood with a set of
loosely held beliefs I would not say
that I was particularly rigid in any of
my beliefs but I got into that system
where um you know it's a very one party
town it's a very very
uh unwelcoming place if you don't tow
the company line and it's able to be
that because of the things that make
Hollywood unique you know there's no
other industry in the world where
someone will go to Harvard Law and then
instead of taking the $250,000 a year
starting pay from all the law firms that
give you an offer just because of having
that credential you go work in the mail
room at ca for subminimum wage y why
would why would that exist well it
exists because people innately
understand the power of an entertainment
they innately understand the power of
narrative the power of story it is more
powerful than practicing law in fact the
law exists within a narrow window
created by culture and so everybody in
the mail room at CAA or UTA or you know
Endeavor William Morris they they all
went to Ivy League schools they all went
to law school they've all given all of
that up to pursue something since you're
pursuing something that cannot be
attained through any guarantee
right we use the term being discovered
that's a silly term but it does speak to
the improbability of success in that
particular field well now you truly are
at the mercy of forces that are not
allowed to exist anywhere else in
business right you you need people to
choose you on the basis of things that
can't easily be described and for that
reason people have enormous power over
you and since they have such power over
you even if they are good people that
power as I said earlier becomes itself
corrosive and so the people who have
that power are corroded by that power
they wield that power over people uh and
one expression of that is Harvey
Weinstein right that you have people who
take sexual advantage of other people
because those people want something that
you alone you're the gatekeeper and you
have power over them but another is
political and and and Theological that
you're able to sort of demand a kind of
Conformity of thought from people and
they're willing to give it because of
the great power that you have to stand
between them and their dreams and I have
a little bit of a natural contrarian
streak I got out there and the Very fact
that those things were expected of you
made me reject them and I rejected them
to my detriment and I rejected them kind
of in that category to of what you
mentioned I wanted the approval of that
system but I wasn't willing to give the
system what would be required to get
that approval there's this yin and yang
happening between my uh my desire to be
loved by those who would not love me is
is there a moment you remember yeah well
there there are a couple that are really
funny one of them is I was sitting at
and and I won't name names here but I
was sitting in one of the biggest
Studios with a fairly prominent actor
who had a deal at that studio at the
time pitching a series that we had
written and and wanted wanted to have
picked up and it was the president I
mean one of the most powerful guys in
the business the president of that
studio took the meeting with not because
of my stature but the statue of my
partner on that project
and he had two female Executives
flanking him you know these these are
the people who develop shows they they
make a good living they've already
flanking him or the president flanking
the president got it and they're hearing
our
pitch I'm sure they all started in the
mail room they all went to Harvard Law
you know flip he's flipping through the
pages he's totally uninterested we're
doing our dog and pony show you know
trying to get a laugh you don't get any
and he gets to a certain page and he
says yeah guys this is fine uh who's the
babe I said what do you mean who's who's
the babe who's going to be the
babe and I said again I don't want to
name names here because the story is
somewhat humiliating but I named a
prominent actress uh who was who was
working at that time as somebody who we
thought would be good for the role and
he said somebody we would know somebody
you would know and he said uh this is
live too so I want to I don't want to
say anything that get you kicked off the
internet but I said uh how about this
gal that's that's kind of who we were
thinking he was like no no no I've
already fed
her you got to give me the gal that I
want to
wow and I was taken aback obviously I
was a young guy at the time naive he
looks over at the G next to him and he
says what about and he named another
somewhat prominent actress he says now
that's a babe I want I mean admit admit
it if you had it you'd
her and I
thought if this If This Were Walmart
tomorrow it would be named Stephanie
Mart or whatever the name of that female
executive for was you know like she
would own this entire company tomorrow
but he has he has a power that a CEO in
a widget Factory does not have he stands
between her and the dream the thing the
the thing to which everyone in that
Community aspires the thing that you
know shows all the guys back in your
small Hometown that they were wrong
about you or whatever it is right of
course and so he has this this power and
and the contrarian in me uh perhap
perhaps the believer in me I recoiled
against that in a way like a snake and
it was a very depressing moment because
I realized uh I am not willing to do
what is necessary to get the love that I
that I desire and so you start thinking
who are my enemies I think that my
enemies are the the people who try to
use coercion and force to impose their
view of the world uh on other people
that that is the thing that I recoil
against the most and you feel it's a
spirit that's alive in our culture right
now sadly it's it's even alive on the
right right now this sort of
authoritarian moment in which we live
predominantly on the left but not not
completely foreign from the current
right I reject that I recoil at it I
despise it uh if my life is dedicated to
anything it's it's fighting for the
ability of me to be my authentic self
the ability of other people to be their
authentic self and I don't mean that in
some sort of loose Lefty uh detached
from reality you should conform to my
that's just another way of using Force
to say you should conform to my view
that's not what I mean uh I mean that
you should get to be the actual you and
that that requires coming up with other
PE coming against other people's
opinions of what you are which is the
thing that the left tries to keep from
ever happening you should never have to
encounter anyone's uh opinion about you
I I want I want to clear all of that out
of the
way th those are the enemies that I
suppose I didn't know I was going to
have when I started out in life and now
I do then there's you know the people
who just come at you or the people who
betray you or the people who hurt you in
some personal way and they they sort of
become your enemy for some reason that
you didn't uh that you didn't see coming
but the the thing that I'm fighting
against I think is is I think I think
coion I think you do good with that
though I think you need it I think your
when's your birthday about what oh
you're February you're a February baby
February 5th February yeah interesting
February 5th
huh very interesting okay uh Rob can you
pull up a friends of ape uh uh Wikipedia
real quick so friends of ape no not
Weinstein okay go to friends of ape so
big difference so friends of AE was a
support and networking group for
politically conservative members of the
film industry and Hollywood organization
was formed in 2004 with Gary sise and
Gary sise was in the movie Payback with
Mel Gibson while the boy he's he's been
a lot of movies but he's a phenomenal
actor Lieutenant Dan He yeah Lieutenant
Dan Forest so with this organization
you I think for five years are the
executive director members uh 2012 I
mean this thing hasn't been updated they
had the pat Boon John void Kelsey gramar
Kevin Soro Scott b a bunch of other
names that are a part of it and since
later W Drew from the leadership and
Hollywood producer Jeremy boring became
executive
director and at one point
uh I think the IRS wanted a section of
the organization's website that would
identify its members since such access
is not required by federal law you did
not you refused to give him that access
to see who it is now did this was for
the longest time a lowkey
underground type of a meeting where they
would get to I don't know
some friends's house whether you
know I know some of these folks and and
um I've I've attended some of these
meetings with some folks but um when
you're part of this organization how
much are they at a point right now where
they're more comfortable being public
about it how much of it is at a point
right now I I got a call who is one of
your friends uh I won't mention his name
I'll tell you off camera and I had a
conversation with him I'm sure you know
who I'm talking about and you know he
calls we have a very good 30 45 minute
conversation on a Sunday he says I watch
on uh Joe on Rogan podcast and I saw
what you want to do with this year you
know I used to be partners with Jeremy
boring and all this other stuff I'm like
okay sounds good and you know the idea
was so many of the people in that
industry are afraid to come out because
they don't want to give up access and
they don't want to give up
losing that possibility of what can
happen there how many of these guys are
getting to a point right now that they
really don't give a and how many
the bigger bigger names I'm talking like
big big names are privately talking to
you guys that they just don't want
anybody to know about their business
yeah uh you know the first rule of
friends of ab is there is no friends of
AE you I I fought they IRS to not have
to reveal the names of anybody in the
organization so of course I'll uh of
course I'll maintain that
but I would say that it it comes in
waves you know a a person has a Breaking
Point and over time a lot of people
individuals have had their breaking
point they're fed up they no longer want
the love of the woman who won't love
them and they're willing to speak out
and that they weren't say in 2012 at the
same time there's there's a whole new
batch of people that that begin their
careers during that period of time in
the the film that we're releasing uh on
Friday lady Ballers has given me a new
opportunity to meet yet another batch of
people working in the industry who don't
want to be known who are terrified of
being found out and I I hate that you
know during my time running friend of
friends of Abe I would host these new
member meetings you'd have 40 people sit
around a table 20 of them would be
existing members and then they would
bring a guest to into the group that was
the only way you could get in and it was
you know it was like a recovery meeting
everybody go around the table introduce
themselves and and confess that they
were
conservative and I would say that over
the years you know even before I became
executive director I would host those
meetings over the years I hosted dozens
and dozens and dozens we had 2,300
members and they all came in through
this system 20 people at a time at a
time it was four or five times maybe Max
that someone didn't break down weeping
one of these new member meetings you
would always hear the same thing you
know if my agent finds out I'm here I'll
never work again if my lawyer finds out
I'm here I'll never work again if my
manager finds out I'll never work again
had a guy in all sincerity say if my
wife finds out what I believe I am
afraid that I will lose my marriage
because the LIE is so powerful out there
the the allegiance to the LIE must be
absolute people live a lie at such a
deep level that their own spouse does
not know their most deeply held and
deeply guarded in that environment
beliefs uh that's I mean obviously it's
it's a tyranny it's evil and it's
despicable so yes there are bigname
people in Hollywood who've gotten fed up
and come out they're bigger name people
you know who have bigger things to risk
if you make $20 million a movie $10
million a movie that's a lot to lose if
you if you stick your neck out there and
one thing that's important to me at
Daily wire important to my partners at
daily wies we make entertainment we're
aware that at most we can offer someone
a job and it's not a very good trade to
give up a career for a job hey come do
our movie cool but then I won't make any
movies after that yeah uh part of what
we have to do through repeated
risk-taking and and repeated learning
and repeated hopefully success is
demonstrate over time that you can
actually build a career working outside
of that system when we do that I think
the floodgates will open and you'll see
a huge Exodus of talent from out of the
mainstream part of that business but you
have to build you have to build it first
yeah you have to build it first and and
I kind of like that approach because
your approach is going to be look if you
want to see that happen eventually you
know subscribe to our membership
subscribe to this you know help us here
help us there we need resources to get
to do this it is like a fundraiser way
of raising Capital to you know it's what
great past I read a a book one time of a
guy that had raised the most money for
charity yet like a record I don't know 6
S8 billion dollars of money he raised
and he wrote a book how to be a
professional beggar and it's it's one of
the I don't know the exact title of the
book it's a small book but it's one of
the best books I read on that topic and
you almost have to present the argument
in a way where the customer has to look
at it as look we just made another movie
so it's not like we're taking the money
and we're paying salary we made another
this we made another this we need no
members no that relationship could work
if you keep delivering with with the
products and services Tom did you did
you have an experience in LA with you
know I think you had a question about
you know friends of Abe yeah you know it
was very interesting um I had an
opportunity to turn around a small uh
Mobile Media Company it was called Go TV
and I a couple people that came to work
with it they saw wow things will be on
mobile this is the dawn this is right
before iPhone so there's no Android or
iOS standard there's flip phones
companies you didn't only make content
you had to make it work on all the
various different phones and what was
interesting is there was a lot of people
that came there and I met two people
that were part of friends of Abe that
were like I think people know what I'm
all about and you know so if I was
making stuff that was a little bit more
conservative or not you know um I you
know I'm just going to have to deal with
that uh I think if you and and this is
before the crack of the whip with
wokeism and how heavy people came down
you know for this is 2009 to 2012 you
know what I'm saying there was there was
a more subtle there's subtle
cancellation there it wasn't a slam door
on your hand yet and I I I met people
who were unafraid to say things but they
certainly didn't want to plant the flag
in their front
yard this is this is the meetings you
used to go to an LA yourself yep I
didn't I didn't go to a friend of a
meeting but I was introduced to two
people uh from it and they explained
what that was going on and I had great I
had uh great respect uh for what they
were doing and for the risk but it just
seemed so different back then because
Pat it was not the hammer actually list
I like that I like what he's saying
first you got to have a platform for
people to feel safe to go to a different
place and then from their pick and
choose look what Ricky Jes said Ricky
Jes in his speech he said I guarantee
you if Isis started a new platform from
the you know next week and they're
giving money away you would call your
agent and say hey get me under when he
was calling out Tim Cook with apples new
thing that they had at Ricky that the
incredible monologue one of the greatest
monologs I've me I've never heard
anybody like the way he hit it come up
here thank you God thank you this and
get you know yeah so uh I don't can't
this will be the last time I and by the
way he said this this will be the last
time I'll ever do it and they bring it
back five times I don't know if they're
going to bring it back after this one
here Rob can you play this clip of what
uh the pope uh did Cath church not
Protestant what they did which is kind
of weird let me read the caption first
before you play the clip if you don't
mind Rob uh uh if you just make it
smaller like you did there you go what
does it say there Pope Francis had lunch
with a bunch of men who think they're
women how do my Catholic friends feel
about this on the hills of francis's
move to allow trans baptism God Parents
this is Rob Starbuck okay go ahead and
play this
clip
hello
so these are these are transgender men
going where Rob they're going to to
lunch I think lunch with the
Pope are they like a bunch of
billionaires that are about to give
money to the church or what's the
occasion
okay Jeremy you see something like this
what do you think about this what do you
think about you know somebody may say
well you know they just went to the
event it's not like he is sitting there
directly with them but what do you think
about the position the pope is taking
with Catholics and he's he's commented
on the lgbtq stuff multiple times and
he's commented on socialism before
multiple times how do you process
this well I think it's important to
start by saying I'm not Catholic yeah I
pointed out earlier that I'm radically
Protestant I I appreciate about
Catholicism that it is a a traditional
Foundation within a society and you know
I think that tradition really matters
it's important to have Heritage it's
important to have a connection to your
heritage one of the problems that we
have in the world right now is a kind of
radical individualism which disconnects
us from community and you you can't have
a culture without a community you can't
have a nation uh without a community and
so organizations like the Catholic
Church are really important even though
I have theological disagreement with
with the Catholic church I don't I don't
view my role in the world as much as I I
want to fight against coercion that that
doesn't mean that I don't want there to
be a common culture doesn't mean that I
want to throw out everything that's
allowed Us in fact if anything I think
that part of our job in the world is to
is to build a future on the best ideas
of the past that's What Separates Me
from being a part of the left who wants
to throw out the past as unambiguously
evil and create something on the basis
of nothing except fantasy and and dream
you I want to continually uh refine and
and hopefully build on the best ideas
that have been passed down to us and the
Catholic church is very important in
that regard to the extent that you know
I I don't know what Pope Francis is
trying to accomplish it seems from you
know I think any Observer could say that
this is not a conservative Pope he comes
from you know a a Liberation theology
South American uh kind of background
he's he's very hostile toward America
and americanism I think that he sees the
the sort of unique American experiment
as being antithetical uh to his papacy
um I'm I'm no I would not consider
myself a friend of the Pope uh so I
don't know what he's trying to
accomplish is he trying to make a
political statement seems like it is he
trying to make a theological statement
about uh you know how we cannot not deny
Grace to people simply on the basis of
them being Sinners well if that's what
he's trying to do I probably agree with
him if you're if you're a saint you
don't need Grace and the entire premise
of Christianity is that all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God and
are redeemed through Christ alone so to
some to some degree just watching the
clip am I unsettled by the clip
certainly can I say that I wildly
disagree with what the pope is trying to
accomplish I don't know what he's trying
to accomplish so it's hard to say if
he's trying to in any way mainstream the
behavior itself if he's trying in any
way to say this thing that you think is
bad is good and now has my blessing I
would think that that was a really
egregious and evil act but I I I
wouldn't from just watching I I don't
know the story I would not let me ask
you a different question let's just say
let's just say you at dailywire are
hosting a uh open Event okay not by
invitation but open Event where I can
you can I can buy tickets to attended
sure and the attendance is you know 500
people for a dinner let's just say sure
would you be opposed to 50 uh
transgenders buying tickets to attend
this daily wired dinner oh well I I may
not like it but to say would I be uh
opposed to it if if I have to be
responsible for my actions if I have an
open dinner and people buy tickets then
they have to be welcome at the event
that's the nature of so so if okay so if
that was the case then the media comes
back and says Jeremy boring CEO of the
conservative Company daily wire has y
dinner with transgenders right sure uh
how you know how should that person be
judged is the market going to say the
conservative is trying to Cave to the
left I'm trying to be as fair to the
pope as possible because you know I'm
I'm being literally the devil's advocate
of The Devil's Advocate if that makes
any sense yeah uh yeah what do you think
about that well the thing about the pope
is he has one of the you know loudest
microphones in the world and my
microphone is not nearly so loud as the
Pope's but I have a fairly prominent
microphone myself so I suppose that if
the media were to come back and say
Jeremy had a dinner here he is having
dinner with trans
people I'm more than cap capable of
clarifying how I found myself in that
position and what my beliefs are one of
the things that I think creates a lot of
problems is when people engage in
deliberate
ambiguity I I don't want to hide my
motives I I want to be very forthright
with my motives I think that if we're
you I think one of the things that makes
the daily wire successful is that we
don't Pander to our audience you know
I'm a lowercase r republican I believe
that we're supposed to represent our
audience and we're supposed to lead our
audience and there's natur tension
between those two uh premises but in in
correctly ordered in a correctly ordered
approach it's important you know what
people think they want that isn't
actually always the thing that they do
want what people think is right in any
given moment may not be right if you
Pander to them then the the obviously
the criticism that's constantly thrown
around about right-wing media that
you're a grifter well it's true if you
only tell people what they want to hear
so that you can make money off of them
you are in fact a grifter if you tell
people what you believe to be true
whether you whether they agree with you
or not well then you're hardly a grifter
you're you're telling the truth I I
think the daily wire uniquely Endeavors
to accurately represent our audience not
betray the value of our audience but
also lead our audience and show them
places where we have disagreement and so
if the pope is engaged in that kind of
behavior he can make that clear right he
can tell us what I like that deliberate
ambiguity and by the way am I reading it
too much and correct me please I'm not I
won't offended I if if I'm getting a
sense that you're encouraging the pope
to start a podcast is is that I think
You' call it a pope cast Okay po I
like the number one podcast in the world
according to Spotify pass up Joe Rogan
his popcast you know he talks about his
position with the the show is called
deliberate ambiguity so but it's also
it's we can't just completely remove
ourselves from people with whom we
disagree you know the the I'm not trying
to present some false Purity to the
world uh I have friends who people who I
care about deeply who are on different
sides of issues than I am and I you know
we we live in this moment where everyone
wants to label you constantly everyone
wants to figure out where you're impure
so that they can expose your impurities
to the world I'm like well it's the
entire basis of my belief system is to
say oh yeah I'm I'm impure what do you
your point I'm not hiding that so so Jer
I want uh I want to ask you a question
so it's funny you say that cuz we were
at we're at church on Sunday and the the
main thing the pastors think was a seat
at the table so basically it was like
you know we have I have nothing against
anybody Jeremy I'll talk with anybody I
love everybody like even those people
that were at the Vatican okay I don't
know the motive I understand but I want
to ask you with this whole phenomenon
that's happening so first of all one out
of four high school kids uh identifies
as
lgbtq um in America uh from 2017 to 2021
Americans youth receiving a diagnosis of
gender dysphoria has tripled in 5 years
even in England the number of girls
identifying as transgender skyrocketed
4,000% 4,000% in 10 years do you think
it's an organic phenomenon or do you
think that it's like a wellth thought
out implemented like social engineering
what what is what is happening why is
this movement taking off so so hardcore
well of course it's a as has been said
by other people it's a social contagion
it it's a thing that can only exist in
this moment of the internet right where
you know young people can and and you
see it I mean it's been well documented
if there's one trans kid in a school
suddenly there's trans kids in the
school right you're you're exposing
people to this idea and the power of a
social contagion is is can reorder
civilization itself I mean the the
Germans imported linen into Russia
during the first world war right like
they knew here is an idea that can bring
our enemies completely to their knees
this one bad idea if you look at your
own life es especially in the west
especially in America in the west this
isn't this isn't true somebody will come
back and say so you're saying people are
starving to death in Africa because of a
bad idea probably but I'm not suggesting
that they necessarily on a personal
level would have the ability to have a
better idea or or to do anything about a
better idea if they had it but I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about in
America in the west today almost every
problem you have in your life is a bad
idea 100% And so the the power of a
single thought to destroy a life is a
thought is far more powerful than a
nuclear bomb and what we have going on
in our culture today is the Confluence
of a small handful of terrible terrible
thoughts the past is bad nothing is
there's no absolute truth
um only the individual
matters uh in a sort of radical way the
collective exists to protect the
feelings of the individual and when you
when you function in that
melu you're you're so vulnerable to to
an idea like you are not what your body
is you are something other than what you
are you are software existing in
Hardware Silicon Valley thinks you can
upload yourself to a computer and that
somehow that continues to be you as
though what you are isn't this what you
are is something ethereal something that
can't be conceived you know in the
Christian tradition there's a new Heaven
and a new Earth and a new body Paul the
Apostle Paul says one day we'll be
tinted in something new uh but you're
you're never you're not just a spirit
occupying some Hardware that can be
interchanged when when you tell people
that they are then of course they're
going to believe that they if they're
not connected to this at all then what
they truly are can only be described by
them and that's uh I think that's what's
causing the 4,000% increase you know
it's crazy you said something um he said
uh uh the the level of speed on how to
culture change from 200 2008 to 2012
2008 a Democrat could not win being pro
gay marriage right yeah and then in 2012
a Democrat could not win being anti- gay
marriage you have to be prone what was
the difference between 2008 and 2012 you
talk about the whole fact that Will and
Grace came out and became the top show
15 million people are watching this and
all this other I thought it was
fascinating the point you made and Will
and Grace got people to say what's wrong
with this what's wrong the power of
media right so the whole concept of what
you know uh we're all doing here we're
taking a different angle than you are if
you do you know if I've talked to you
about this time I don't want you to say
it if you don't know it I actually
curious to know and Rob don't Google
this cuz I want you to participate as
well do you know who produced the first
Titanic Oh you guys GNA have a I'm so
who produced It produced the who
produced the movie or the movie
Titanic oh you're GNA love this Jeremy
by the way you should get
this yeah I mean the film was produced
by John landow right no there was one
Titanic before that same exact thing but
someone produced it first Tom do you
know the answer to this or no do you
know the answer to this I should are you
ready to flip out and you're going to
flip the F out you ready what if I told
you it was Adolf Hitler what go type in
hit go rob all I want you to do is go
type in Titanic movie 1943 watch this
and Vinnie you just prompted this
thought I wasn't even thinking about
this go right there okay zoom in so we
can read this together Titanics in 1943
German propaganda film made during the
World War II in Berlin by tobas
productions for UFA depicting the
catastrophic sinking of the arms Titanic
in 1912 this was the third German
language dramatization of the event
following a silent film release in 1912
just four months after the sinking of
the British German film Titanics was
commissioned Bingo by Nazi propaganda
Minister Joseph goel with the intent of
showing not only the superiority of
German filmmaking but also as a
propaganda vehicle that would depict
British and American capitalism as being
responsible for the disaster the
addition of an entirely fictional heroic
German officer Peterson to the ship's
crew was intended to demonstrate the
superior bravery and selflessness of the
German men as compared to British
officers the whole movie is about
painting Nazi soldiers as Heroes as
strong as powerful America and Britain
as weak and a money came from Adolf
Hitler the power of making movies can
change elections can change presidents
can cause Wars can cause new policies
can cause a lot of different things oh
movies music if you think about it like
like Taylor Swift doing her thing I'm I
know she she wasn't she's not political
Jeremy she did say something political
during Hillary time but I I was telling
people this don't be surprised she opens
her mouth and tells these people her her
swifties to vote that is such power and
influences and it changes the world well
listen Stalin was heavily involved in
Hollywood uh in the 40s and 50s it's how
we ended up with Ronald Reagan you know
he was the head of uh sag and he was so
opposed to the influence of Stalin I
mean the the people who are willing to
wield tools to make you other than you
are are keenly aware of the power of the
tools that you take for granted that's
it because they're the one looking
they're the ones looking for those
weapons and you're naively not and so
we' we've seeded some of the greatest
most powerful mechanisms ever created to
people who are our ideological enemies
because of naivity you know what's
interesting some of these case studies
of media are living in uh plain sight in
the 70s remember uh soap operas were
very big the afternoon there was nothing
much on except soap operas General
Hospital Young and Restless One Life to
Live you can go and take a look at them
take the tour of NBC and it's like the
history of the growth of the soap opera
but did you also in terms of social
contagion do you know when soap operas
would invent diseases you would have
thousands of housewives that would go to
their doctor and
actually we're dealing with
psychosomatic symptoms that they're
bringing on themselves about fictitious
diseases that they saw in a soap opera
and we looked at that comically but
really that was a foreshadowing of how
easily we were all led by media the
Power Media by the way you know what the
movie Jan Q did to me the movie Jan Q I
don't you've seen JN Q with Denzel
Denzel conell is in it there's a bunch
of guys in it's a very good movie if you
watch the movie JN Q by the time you're
done it was the perfect timing for
ObamaCare to be accepted wow because
John Q I did see John Q I
remember I don't bury my kid my kid my
son buries me right that whole scene
when he's getting emotional yeah Y and
don't show this by the way Rob I mean
the the people in the back it's just so
John Q the movie uh shows the fact that
they need a heart uh uh transplant for
the kid and they have to spend uh some
what uh quarter a million dollars know
it's a big amount of money and they're
like yeah we can't cover that we can't
do that with the insurance so that got
the average person to watch the movie
and said that's not fair that's not this
so it stays there's so much power in
movies movies and music can destroy an
entire civilization that's how powerful
it is
so and by the way what was this prompted
by you said something about you know
when you read the stats one out of four
and you know 3,000% and all these things
that you're G 4,000% you know what my
problem is with the Pope here's what my
problem is with the pop and it's the
same thing problem I have when I go and
talk to some other you know Christian
you know pastors or different people
that are calling for you know business
marketing Consulting is you're too
tolerant you you you you're too tolerant
with wanting to uh compromise your
values and principles and standards you
know what was one of my difficult
interviews I ever did that was so
painful for me when I did this interview
I was within 30 minutes I'm like man I
I'm I don't want to do this interview
anymore Mike dka let me tell you why
Mike dka I don't know if you know Mike
dka you know shakago Bears you know hey
here's a quarter go talk to someone who
cares I don't want to talk to you I
would much rather talk to that guy right
there he was the best you know what do
you call it post game interview guy my
he's maybe the goat of postgame
interview I freaking loved watching this
guy and I interview him and I asked him
a question about Colin Kaepernick cuz it
was that time when he got fired from
ESPN for making comments about
Kaepernick I don't know if you remember
this and and he says you know maybe I
was too hard maybe I was wrong maybe I
was too tough maybe I'm like no you were
not bro you were right like I'm trying
to as a fan to say no don't let them do
this to you you were right you're a
leader we need more people like you we
need you to stay strong we don't need
need you to Cave we need you to stay
like you know what's the word where
somebody can get you to bend and
apologize going to freaking apology to
her no you were right his wife is
sitting right next to us while I'm doing
the interview you know I think we
need more people that are sitting there
saying look man I love you guys I don't
agree with you yeah this is not right
I'm not tolerant to it this doesn't mean
I don't love you this doesn't mean you
and I can't have a conversation together
this doesn't mean we can't have dinner
together you know
some people say well Pat you know you're
anti-muslim and you're anti- this and
you're anti- this let me say something
most people don't know that they need to
know I'm Armenian I'm a Syrian okay and
I'm a Christian my chef who's in my
house every day how many days a week 5
days a week he cooks for all of us you
ready he's Turkish and he's a Muslim
most people don't know this story I
don't brag about it I don't need to brag
about it I love this guy he's amazing to
my kids we have to best conversations
together when we first did the interview
he's like you know I'm Turkish I'm like
you know I'm Armenian yeah I know I said
do you do you want to hurt me no I said
I don't have any desire for you to do
anything to you either man if I get
along with you we can sit there and talk
great we can have our differences we can
have the conversation I'm a Muslim no
problem all good we'll sit there and
have the conversation he has different
positions all the stuff that's going on
I think there's a difference between
having love Yeah and still being able to
disagree so I don't like that a leader
as big as him there isn't anybody bigger
than the Pope Joel ain's not bigger than
the pope we don't have a Billy Graham
today there's no modern day Billy Graham
going around baptizing 210 million
people he's got a lot of influence
behind him and I actually don't agree
with the positions he's taken and I
think he's being too tall and just just
to throw this out there I know Italians
from Italy you think they're happy about
what he's doing no the most conservative
countries in Europe jery I was just
going to say the people that I know that
are like hey I think they're like anti
everything that he's doing and they're
furious at what he's doing Furious go
ahead Tom you you know the history of
presidential approval ratings agree with
you 100% on the topic of leadership
against a clear backdrop presidential
approval ratings rise when the president
is taking a firm stand against a clear
backdrop and it's never been social it's
never been social oh the Red Wave didn't
happen in the last election because of
abortion well it was hell of a lot more
than that you know did that help no but
there is a lot more to it you take a
look at W's approval rating and
Clinton's approval rating when they had
clear backdrops that they were against
and their approval rating was up then
when they ran to the center they either
got yep you know they they the the
approval rating slipped and and
Clinton's approval rating wasn't
slipping because people were appalled
that he had you know a an affair and
what happened happened they they were
not inspired against a clear backdrop
the best place to go look at it is last
week the Argentine people are not insane
they are not they saw a Clear Choice
against a very clear backdrop and you
can see that the populace runs to that
and so you can boil a a frog in a pot
slowly but when the frog is at the point
of being cooked against a clear backdrop
that's when the voters will respond and
I I think I think the pope is just
Meandering through social social
dynamics I think he's on like a like a
photo tour yeah he's a he's a Seeker
friendly Pope something that you
typically associate with uh Protestants
right this sort of secret friendly
American Christianity movie movement
that that is what he seems to be I I'm
agreeing with you to your point I mean
once you against a clear backdrop the
people will follow because they'll say
that's my guy and by the way that's what
the Dems don't understand about Trump
he's so clear let me give you the other
side though that's also not what the
leaders on the other end don't
understand that they have to stand up
and have backbone and not freaking Bend
every damn time they fear losing
something like you know you know you
said you said uh the the the the scene
with the you your friend the two girls
the president who I have enough to this
this that whole thing that you were
talking about right in that moment your
dream may have been I want to get an
Oscar I want to do this I want to do
that I want to do this that dream of a
12-year-old kid Leck where you from what
part of Texas just outside of L just out
uh uh uh Garza what was the thing about
the uh uh yeah the gar of theater yeah
so so this is a kid that has a dream and
now you're grown man you're going into
you're having a meeting with people that
you want to have and then that happens
in that moment you have to make a
decision values principles am I willing
to compromise or not it's a very hard
place to be but we need more people that
are intolerant with values and
principles yet loving gentle able to
give their argument and allowing other
people to to agree or disagreeing and go
do your own thing I don't care if you
disagree fine I still respect you but
this is my position you don't want to do
anything think about a salute to you
love you but this is where I stand with
this and I'm not willing to compromise
this I think we need more of that anyway
so this is a perfect transition into the
trailer do we have your permission to
show the trailer here on the podcast
absolutely okay Rob go ahead and play
this trailer okay this is so before we
play this clip can you tell us 30
seconds what it's about and then we'll
play the trailer for The Audience to see
yeah the movie is called lady Ballers
that's my entire description if you
can't get it from that lady Ballers yeah
it's a it's a about some high school
state champ whose basketball players
whose best days are behind them until
they figure out that they can go
dominate women sports just by saying
that they're women and nothing else this
thing got 20 million views in 48 hours
go ahead and play it in a world where
women's
sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
year
guys this is serious sports can be your
pathway to a better life well like yours
please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient in becoming a winner now
maybe you should T in
time are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you could beat them what
do you know about the US opens the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day Jo this is
the way the world is now my 8-year-old
daughter told me all about it so a guy
can become a girl with no physical
changes at all oh that's called
gingering so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom I can't
believe it nice you mean when you're
sleeping yes coach Al we can play
basketball we have to get the whole team
back to together it's time we're in I'm
in I'm in to play Lady balers M
up like a girl that's what I'm with
[Applause]
her my truth this is my
truth from Heroes day one of being a
girl
athlete I love being a girl to Sho we
could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
[Music]
Felix ladies basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats
open never mind getting
D Kentucky
TR she
that's the biggest I've ever seen on a
lady I don't care Lady
B I don't one can even be trans aged now
which provides shelix with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school streaming exclusively on daily
wire DEC I can't wait to read the
reviews on Rotten Tomato that's what I'm
interested in I want to read the review
you so uh uh obviously funny as hell the
trailer I haven't seen a flick yet this
comes out when on Friday on Friday
Friday okay so and it's going to be only
on daily wire plus daily wire plus okay
now when you see the final product right
now yourself what feeling do you have is
it because I know you what you're
thinking about is like that clip with
your head hitting the table did it
actually hurt cuz that look like you
actually hit the table it hurt and I did
it 30
times here's the thing about hitting
about being a St stunt guy you know like
Tom Cruz does all of his own stunts that
sucks uh this wasn't able to be done by
a stunt guy and so they said yo you're
going to have to do
it you're quick hit your head on the
table everything about your body is
programmed to break your fall yeah and
so the thing about the thing about doing
that stunt if you're not a crazy stunt
guy uh who's already beat all of this
Common Sense out of yourself is that you
try to stop yourself but you also know
that you have to pull off the stunt on
camera so all you're doing is ensuring
that you're going to have to do it again
and again and it still hurts every time
it's not like you're not hitting the
table can you imagine you can't be like
Hey listen guys I'm only doing this one
I swear to God you better get it well
because I wasn't good enough to do it
like I I wouldn't let myself fully
commit to it until I'd had all the sents
beat out of me and then you got the good
one so oh I'm sorry what's what's a
budget for something like this I think
we spent 7 million 7 million on this y
it looks it looks very good looks very
good can't wait to see it on December
1st go ahead you a question so Jeremy it
comes out exclusively on daily wire yep
Plus or just regular daily daily wire
plus daily wire plus got you got you so
Jeremy what what are the odds if if it's
and and we hope we hope so we hope for
you it's it's really successful online
is there any chance for it to be to to a
point where you're like okay people want
to see it people really love it we want
to put it out in the theater how how
would that work y it it won't we met
with some theatrical distri uh
Distributors I think the film would do
very well in theaters in
fact I think that it would out kick its
coverage in theaters because right now
theaters are in trouble right Disney
bombed at the box office this weekend uh
almost every film since the pandemic has
done poorly at the box office with with
precious few exceptions but for the
right going to the theater can be an act
of protest buying a subscription to the
Daily wire is not an act of protest so I
think it would do much better in
theaters than it will on our platform
here's the
problem that movie ain't going to no
theaters unless just you you warn
everybody one of the one of the top
agents at UTA came to us years ago not
that many years ago a couple of years
ago and said hey we'd love to work with
you guys we can do some huge things
together and I said you there's no way
you'll ever do huge things with us we
believe this we believe that he said
yeah yeah yeah we don't care about any
of that we just care about you know
there's an opportunity here we want to
take it he said the only thing is you
got to back off this trans issue said I
don't care what you say about abortion
don't care what you say about religion
don't care what you say about who to
vote for don't care what you say about
taxes got to back off this trans issue
this is the religious issue of our time
for the left this represents the
culmination of their religious beliefs
uh and so when we went to theatrical
Distributors there it was a we not even
going to engage in the conversation it's
not that they passed it was just like
here's a great example the Hollywood
trades have covered every movie we've
made at Daily wire so far they won't
even write about this one and and I
understand because that would be putting
themselves on the other side of the
actual religion that matters within
their industry so yeah uh sadly while I
think that we will have a theatrical
strategy for many of our films going
forward in the future there's no way
this that ain't the one by the way you
know what's crazy though here's what's
crazy so Klay Travis comes out and says
I'll put a bit put a million dollars on
my own money I don't know if you saw
this time Klay Travis from outkick he
gives a million bucks saying I am
willing to say I'll pick the high school
high school kids high school boys a High
School boys basketball team will beat
the WNBA
Champions have you seen this or no okay
check this out then one of the players
responds back and calls him clown or
whatever right he comes back and says
well if you're so confident why don't
you do it no word Pat Beverly comes out
and Pat Beverly says you're an idiot he
calls him something like you're you're
on drugs okay and then Klay Travis says
well maybe I'm on drugs he says but both
of us are millionaires why don't you put
your million dollars yes on the WNBA and
why don't I put the million dollars on a
high school team and let's see who wins
never got back to him okay never got
back to him he has
cornered these ladies and the entire
Sports mainstream media and athletes who
think WNBA is this incredible sport that
people want to watch and you're like
don't worry nobody watches wnb and all
this other stuff it just it shows
contradiction and hypocrisy in the
argument to say it's just not real you
know who's the best person that said
what she said in 2012 or 13 when she
says Andy Murray playing against me he
would Crush Serena Serena William said
David Letterman and David Letterman
couldn't say anything about it now I
don't know if she would say today she
said that about 10 years ago whatever it
was what a movie like this does you know
what it does it gets you thinking the
challenge for me is the people that
watch Daily wire are already
understanding look at this I would lose
60 60 to Andy Murray in 10 minutes
that's right when Serena Williams said
this so guess what respect to her being
straight up about it and gu and she
still makes a lot of money she makes a
20 million year she's very wealthy she's
the goat she's won 22 23 24 a couple
Champion couple major she's she beats
stepy graph and she's done a lot of
great things she's one of the greatest
female tennis players of all time she
deserves her success maybe the greatest
some would say of all time right but the
the purpose of this movie this is where
my my concern
goes is the people that need to watch it
may not pay to watch it on daily wire
the people that need to watch it need to
watch to be sitting there saying what a
stupid thing this is so is the plans and
and I don't know what you're going to
say to this maybe this is the plans cuz
you know the uh could be part of the
Playbook where you guys did what is a
woman and you first had it on dailywire
Plus for a couple years whatever the
timeline was and then you put it on
Twitter and got 100 million views within
24 hours and Elon Musk retweeted it is
the plans for this to be on dailywire
Plus for about a year or two and then
you put it on Twitter to get the
eyeballs of the you know regular folks
to watch and say holy this makes a
lot of sense yeah I I would say that
well first you know we're we're often
accused of preaching to the choir but
preaching to the choir is who you preach
to the choir is who listens and the
reality baptize though you got to
baptize as well but who does that and
and this is my actual argument you you
preach to the choir because it's the
choir who goes out and has relationships
one-on-one which is actually where most
people change their mind I changed my
mind about my theology because I had a
great Professor for my very very very
brief stint uh College I had a a
professor who would argue with me about
religion and I never was even conscious
of the fact that I changed my views I
just slowly over time found that when I
was talking to other people I was saying
not the things that I would say to him
but the things that he would say back to
me and then one day in a moment of
self-reflection I went he actually
changed my mind I actually believe
something now that is distinct from what
I believed before that's how most of us
come to our beliefs it's from our close
Community it's from our friends it's
from mixing it up it's not from watching
the B Shapiro show sure some people
watch the Ben chapiro show a lefty will
watch the Ben chapiro show boom they're
a conservative that's rare far more
likely is a conservative watches the Ben
chapiro show they now get ammunition for
how to actually articulate and actually
think about these issues then they go
out into the world and have
conversations with people with whom they
disagree and those people make change so
I I don't think preaching to the choir
is n bad I think it's good but it's not
it's not sufficient obviously there's
the next thing that needs to happen with
with what is a woman as you say we put
it on uh put it on Twitter on the Oney
year anniversary and had an enormous
success with it will we do that with
this well I don't know what we will do
with this but certainly we are
constantly innovating and evolving and
thinking about how to reach people so
whether that's whether that's putting it
on X or whether it's some other strategy
uh C certainly we're going to find
broader and broader audiences for our
content over time well it sounds like
you're subscribing to basically the um
the execution of apologetics I'm going
to give you the way to argue and then
I'm going to let you go work with the
people that you know and love on a more
onetoone basis I'm not going to expect
you to to convert you know in the
amongst the mob you know but there are
some that are breaking through um you
know uh South Park's panders episode has
been you're smiling has been absolutely
destroying Disney and Kennedy it showed
uh it went after Kennedy the woman who's
been redoing all these Kennedy yep all
the she's been responsible for all the
bombs and that happened under Chek
because it's the release WI window s is
what um Iger was dealing with when he
showed up but all this was done there
there are some people that are doing it
I mean they've got that um they took
that platform got it on Paramount plus
and it it it's out there everybody's
seeing it and Disney is reacting trying
to keep it off and they're doing
everything they can to fight it and God
bless whoever at Paramount plus said no
no no no no that's part of the series
that's that satire that's cartoon we're
going to leave it on but that thing was
heavy-handed you know what's crazy about
his movie too P before I know you want
to move on
people can actually do like I know it's
a movie but though guys could literally
today do exactly what you guys did in
the movie say that they're women and do
exactly what he's doing like nothing's
holding you back well they are doing it
this is the thing ex they are doing it
the scene that's in the trailer and and
I'll stop I'll stop self-promoting it's
all good the scene in the trailer where
Blaine crane lifts is wrestling he lifts
the woman off the ground and smashes her
first of all it hurt she's a
professional stunt woman and it was
painful and it was painful to watch and
when I was driving home actually had a
moment of reflection that night and
thought what is this immoral am I doing
something wrong like we we we humiliated
that gal I mean she signed up for it
she's a professional but you don't feel
great about it and then I realized oh no
this is this isn't even a joke the first
male MMA fighter who identified as a
woman and fought an actual biological
woman broke her skull almost killed her
yep broke her skull all we're all we're
doing is what they did in death of
Stalin we're saying No this is reality
and it's okay to laugh at it exactly are
you calling it inspired by true events I
should have you should have honestly you
should have cuz that's should have by
the way you know uh uh uh have you read
musk's book Walter isacson or no no okay
I'm gonna give you a line I think it's
the best line this is one of my favorite
quotes uh recently that I've read the
quote says uh in musk's book uh it's
fantastic it says uh musk likes to take
the fiction out of Science Fiction what
a powerful thing to say what a powerful
thing to say musk likes to take the
fiction out of Science Fiction you could
have called this based on true events
and people would said that makes a lot
of sense so let's talk about Disney and
uh Marvel so Disney admits the left it's
leftwing policies hurt share
shareholders in new SEC filing Disney is
not admitting that it is uh uh it's been
slapped by its own customers for its
far-left social and political agenda
legal expert Jonathan Turley wrote in
the recent column Disney's SEC filing we
face risks relating to misalignment with
the public and consumer tastes and
preferences for entertainment travel and
consumer products which impact demand
for entertainment offering and products
and that profitability profitability of
any of our businesses we Face risk
related to changes in our business
strategy or restructuring of our
business which has
affected and may continue this past
summer Disney stock had hit a nine-year
low with its marketing cap fa falling
from $350 billion in March of 2022 to
$154 billion a decline of Vinnie you
ready they lost
$196 billion in one year what $196
billion a 56% drop off in a little over
a year and then at the same time they're
talking about what happened with wish
Disney's animated musical comedy wish
has a disappointing box office debut
earning approximately 1995 million over
the 3-day Thanksgiving and 31.7 million
to 5 days this film marks Disney's 100
100 anniversary celebration features a
cosmic Force named star and sharp wited
heroin her hero named Asha The Hunger
Games and the B lines get top 20 so when
you see these types of things and by the
way this is back to back to back to back
to back it's becoming a trend with
Disney you know Bob Iger wrote a great
book called the right of a
lifetime and then he made the mistake of
coming back okay that's right this guy
comes back and now the sequel of that
book should be a ride of a lifetime with
a shitty return okay
okay maybe the best dealmaker we've had
in the last 40 years he sat with the
biggest alphas and bought their
companies Lucas jobs you know Murdoch I
I don't know how many other names I can
say he's done it all right stud of a guy
great executive do you think one any of
this is his blame is it Sheek is it do
you think he's sitting there regretting
his return and all in all why do you
think Disney knowing that this has
happened and they continue doing it or
is it the fact that the pipeline of
these movies have taken three to five
years to make that they're kind of like
let's get the all these shitty movies
out and then we'll change our philosophy
next year but it's not going to take
it's going to take us three to five
years to recover with the next movies
that are going to come out well I think
you've got there's a lot there to unpack
first I'll say is any of it Bob iger's
fault of course it is
right Bo Bob Iger wasn't uninvolved in
setting the stage for what was going to
come after him you know you you're not
Bob Iger and then shock shocked and
dismayed to figure out who they replace
you with uh so yeah B Bob Iger put a lot
of this in place yes one of the great
Executives of our time as to why he came
back you know does Michael Jordan still
play basketball it's almost impossible
to ever walk away from the thing that
you're uniquely gifted at and we see it
with professional athletes all the time
that they they come back after their
Heyday and and and do poorly but they
can't walk away from the game so I get
that he can't walk away from the game
and he can't walk away from his legacy
and he's a greater executive than
anybody at this table will ever be but
that doesn't mean that he hasn't made
his billion dollar mistakes and I think
he's he's dealing with one right now yes
the window of time that it takes for
these things to come out is a huge part
of it if Disney decided today uh we're
only going to make movies about Bible
stories well you wouldn't get one of
those movies about Bible stories for 3
years there's just that's just the
reality of of what that process looks
like so so that's part of what they're
fighting against but I think the biggest
problem that they have and I know this
from many many incredibly gifted people
within Disney with whom I've I've spoken
over the last
year they fired
everyone who knows how to engage in
traditional storytelling without all of
this woke nonsense in it they created
such a bubble over there that even if
Bob Iger does say Bob if Bob Iger came
out today and said we're not even going
to release the crap we're going to take
the hit and then starting on a day three
years from today we're going to relaunch
Disney he he doesn't have the team to do
it he said recently you know we we've
waited too far into politics and now
we're going to now we're going to not
pick these controversial political
fights anymore the people that the
people actually working for him who have
to effectuate that plan do not know the
difference between the controversial
things they believe and the
uncontroversial things that they believe
because they exist within a company
that's a bubble within an industry that
is a bubble within a city that's a
bubble within a state that's a bubble
that entire you know well documented the
the right understands the left we
disagree but we understand the left does
not understand the right the left does
not understand themselves Disney has
engaged in the greatest act of brand
suicide that has probably ever happened
in recorded history the most beloved
brand the most Goodwill with the most
important people parents on behalf of
the most uh uh the most vulnerable
people children we we trust Disney for
three consecutive Generations we as
adults trust Disney with our children
Disney helped shape the worldview of
every single adult in this country we
trusted them so much that we gave them
tax breaks all over the like all the
Goodwill that came their way because
they were so unique and they created the
greatest Content Library ever assembled
in all of human
history and then they squandered it the
the lesson there for anybody engaged in
any kind of business is is enormous uh
that if you think that you
are more powerful than your audience you
have complet lost the plot and Disney
has completely lost the plot I don't
think Bob Iger you know can he get their
share price up over time maybe or maybe
he'll just sell it to Apple which is I
think what's try to I think that's
what's going to happen yeah he's going
to sell he's going to sell it tole
pieces he'll sell it to Apple and it'll
become even more radical because Apple
can afford for a time to be disconnected
from the audience they can't afford it
forever it's crazy same same thing with
the Budweiser you know I mean Bud Light
how insane how how do you even think in
that meeting and I and I I remember the
girl that was in charge Rob I forgot I
forgot her name but she's the one that
made the decision she had the all the
rainbow stuff and stuff behind her a a
beer whack guy normal drinking country
and you put Dylan Mulaney and like I I
would put them at at number two for the
worst decision for the worst for your
people to be like what an overnight
shotgun I don't know how many billions
that they lost but call the customers
are the customers for budlight are very
fratty we need to we need to grow but at
what point go W go bro like like
how many more times how many more
instances have to happen until these
people actually wake up like genuinely
wake up cuz it's billions and Bill it's
not like okay five we lost $5 million
okay we can move on this is billions and
billions of dollars here's your problem
the the problem is that the left has
complete hegemony in the culture today
and one of the consequences of that
problem a is that they don't know but B
is that there are no true consequences
so has she lost her job it if she has
lost her job where is she working now
exactly because the the left will
reinforce these bad behaviors even if
Bud fires her someone else will hire her
in fact they'll hire her and Pat
themselves on the back for their act of
heroism in rescuing her from the
persecution of the other company that
fired her they they can't get rid of it
comes full circle that they are so
committed to this bad thought this this
bad idea that is in their head that in
times of relative peace and Rel of
prosperity they're willing to just
engage in self
flagellation over and over and over
again do you know what zombie companies
are are you fam with Z zombie companies
so zombie companies are companies that
the their their actual business model
doesn't make money it only makes money
to pay operating
expenses and the debt aside from that
there's no profit so they don't have
money to invest into it okay right
zombie companies rely on debt to grow
for
example in 1997 in America according to
the FED 1% of companies in America were
zombie companies today according to
Goldman and according to the FED 25% of
companies today are zombie companies by
the way Ford is a zombie Company Fort is
a zombie company Sears was a zombie
company they F bankruptcy JC Penney was
a zombie company they F bankruptcy toys
a Russ was a zombie company they F
bankruptcy iHeart media is a zombie
company they're getting destroyed
they're filing bankruptcy so what what
what happens with zombie companies the
reason why the increase of zombie
companies went from 1% to
25% is because of the interest rates
going to 0% okay for as long as it did
and when it went to 0% these companies
are like hey let's just keep it getting
there by the way Ford just got $9.3
billion last year that's how they're
surviving for three quarters they were
negative NE three years they were
negative negative negative and now
barely they're coming out of it because
uh Biden gave them 9.3 billion dollar
saying hey these guys going to be an EV
company you're not a freaking EV company
the other guys are EV companies but
totally get it so the whole too big to
fail you know they were afraid to let
these companies go out of business so
this whole you know the tarp program
that they came you know came up with and
most people don't even know what tarp
stands for can you Google what tarp
stands for okay so tarp oh the tarp
progr it's just a tar program what a
good tarp program tarp program uh is
troubled asset relief program troubled
is the T troubled asset so let's bail
out troubled asset relief program
instead of letting Capon do its part
here's the problem when like these
companies I just said the the seers JC
Penney iHeart media po R they all filed
bankruptcy between 2016 to 2020 here's
what happened happen when Trump became
president he appointed Jerome Powell to
chair of the FED I think he used to be
yelling before I don't know who it was
but I think he points Powell when Powell
comes in he starts increasing rates if
you go to 2017 rates started increasing
and even Trump wasn't a fan of the fact
that he was increasing rates so when the
increase rates these companies are like
dude you can't do that we're trying to
borrow money the only way we can last is
through debt you can't be doing this so
the more if the interest rates today
Powell keeps them the way he does
companies like Disney and a lot of these
companies have to be bought by somebody
else because they're not going to be
able to last a lot of these zombie
companies are going to get destroyed the
longer rates stay high and the
correlation between interest rates being
High and zombie companies being exposed
is identical and the rates being lower
and the increase in Zombie companies is
identical so you notice that Trend so at
the end of the day you can pitch the
woke all you want guess what the
customer's going to say get the hell out
of here and then you going to be another
zombie company that once was a great
company where the founders crying
watching down if he's in heaven saying
what the hell did you guys do to that
company that I put tens of thousands of
hours of my life being away from the
kids the family rode I was sick I was
still doing conference calls the anxiety
the panic attacks the times I was
dealing with health issues that I
couldn't advertise because God forbid
you know I how to meet a secret doctor
so the public wouldn't talk about it
they're they're about to pay a price and
I'm willing to say the person that
controls which one of these companies
get exposed at zombie companies as
Jerome Powell if Jerome Powell decides
to decrease the rates it'll be the
return of the zombies literally it'll be
the return to zombies but if Jerome
Powell keeps the rates high for the for
another year and a half and he doesn't
get fired you're going to see the next
year and a half two years some of these
guys getting picked up by other people
who are better at operating expenses who
are better at making profits who are
better at running a company and uh like
you know we had a a couple of the
competitors there they're raising money
buying companies they're raising money
buying companies when rates are very low
okay then all of a sudden your rates are
if they're adjustable and all of a
sudden it's going up and it like you
know re-triggers every two three years
you're like Hey we're okay at 3% we
can't freaking pay this at 7 and a half%
you saw what happened to the interest
rates what the hell are we talking about
right now and you're like you got to be
cheaper on the way you're spending the
money so they can do this all they want
the market if rates stay high is going
to topple a lot of these companies and
they'll get exposed and Bob is just
trying to sell it cuz Disney stock it's
just going to go lower and lower and
lower and apple is sitting they're
saying yeah we'll buy you but in another
year we'll save another 33% why would we
buy today we'll still going to buy you
you'll be an Apple company but we'll
wait we wait a year we'll save $50
billion and I know they like to have
their cash um did you watch Napoleon the
movie I've have not been to the movies
do you like walking Phoenix I think he's
the greatest living actor okay we're on
the same page to me he top three I think
walking is phenomenal um do you know the
story about how much the budget was are
you following any of the story with
Napoleon yeah I've been overseas I
haven't been into it okay so $200
million to make Ridley Scott yeah yep
Ridley Scott 200 million to make to
break even they needed to do $400
million opening week they did $79
million oh missed it by
$321
million I sat there took you know 10 12
family members were sitting there watch
an entire movie together I couldn't
believe they wasted a year of waen
Phoenix's life to make this shitty movie
okay it was more like a documentary you
know how they do these documentaries
where there's like actual actors dressed
like Warriors you know what I'm I don't
know what they call it reenactment re
you what I'm talking re that's what I
felt when you're done watching it it's
another example of destroying a western
leader and only showing his weakness and
he's walking around like a little weak
man insecure rather than the general
that he was not a single point in the
movie did I even was I even tempted to
cry how do you make a three-hour movie a
2hour 45 minute movie and not make me
cry single time Josephine dies there was
not a moment where I was like emotional
about the way you took me there you had
an opportunity to take this movie in a
way where you know it almost reminded me
of when Colin Ferrell did Alexander
remember when Colin Ferell Alexander
like 30 years ago it was a another Miss
and they're like this was a bad job they
did for portraying who Alexander was and
all this other
stuff very disappointing when I watch
this uh myself uh Walkin when you watch
Walk the Line when you watch some of
these movie you think like dude the
guy's a freaking Beast this is a a very
much of a Mis job I know you watch it as
well with me it was one of those movies
where cuz normally if it's a good movie
I'm not going to the bathroom I don't
care I'll even time the drinking of the
water throughout the day I went to the
bathroom three times and came back and
it was still just cuz like he said at
least in Gladiator and I mean you can't
you can't compare the two obviously but
Gladiator it started with the war you
know they killed his wife they they hang
the wife it's this was just like a day
in the life of Napoleon and like Pat
said just week and you know the girl was
kind of you know she was in charge and
like zero emotion zero excitement and
like I said I walked away you could have
I think like for people that have kids
you could just if the kid's not going to
sleep play this movie and the kid will
pass out instantly it it's a cure for
insomnia that's what it was well if
there's one thing I know it's that the
the greatest General and conqueror maybe
in human history was definitely whipped
by his wife who is really the the one
calling all the shots no no question
about it yeah Josephine the Conqueror
yeah she was Josephine the great the
last three words he says the the the
last three words before he died was
France Army Josephine the last three
words and and they he tweeted it out I
think when he said that Napoleon yeah
they they still have it it was a and you
know what my my three words when we left
the theater was Patrick never again yeah
that's right that was those were my
three words never again are you
following what's going on in Dublin and
what Conor McGregor said to you know the
whole uh uh challenge that's taking
place there wanting to take uh refugees
following that story let's read let's go
through I know a little bit about what's
happening in Ireland but not the Conor
mcord okay so let's let's read this and
then we'll get your commentary on it so
yeah Dublin se's worst writing in
decades after children stabbed this is a
Wall Street Journal story
Dublin witnessed its worst civil
disorder in decades resulting in 13
damage shops 34 arrests and the
deployment of over 400 police officers
guard of commissioner Drew Harris
attributed the violence to lunatic
hooligan faction driven by the far-right
ideology the riots following a stabbing
attack outside a school leaving three
children injured and 5-year-old girl in
critical condition a man in his 50s was
taken into custody in the incident spark
rumors online Irish Prime Minister Leo
vatar condemned the riters warning of
potential further protests and
emphasizing the need for review of the
event of violence has also raised
questions about migration in Ireland
with around 141,000 migrants immigrants
entering the Republic between a damn
April 2022 and April 2023 according to
government figures the majority coming
from Ukraine and while this is taking
place Conor
McGregor rips the Irish government uh
appears to hint at political aspirations
Conor mcregor Rob if you got the Tweet
the US UFC Superstar criticized the
current state of Ireland amid protests
McGregor said I do not condone last
night's rights I do not condone any
condone any attacks uh of on our First
Responders in their duty of line of duty
I do not condone looting and the
damaging of shops McGregor emphasized
the need for action and change in
Ireland hinting at potential aspirations
he stated I am in the process of
arranging believe me I am way more
technical uh and I have have backing
there will be change in Ireland markk my
words McGregor also warned that if
officials don't act to ensure Ireland's
safety he would take matters into his
own hands saying if they do not take
action soon with their plan of action to
ensure Ireland safety I will so what are
your thoughts on what's going on there
well first of all the the greatest bad
idea of the 20th century is that you can
have unfettered immigration uh you know
IM immigration is important obviously
America is an immigrant country but the
Melting Pot uh theory of immigration
requires you not to change fundamentally
the taste of the soup you you you see
what I mean you have to bring in people
who either align with the soup and so
bringing them in doesn't change the
flavor of the soup or you bring in
people who don't but in small enough
numbers that the soup assimilates the
ingredient the ingredient doesn't
overpower the soup and that worked very
well in this country for a long time and
in the second half of the 20th century
we threw that completely out the door
and we said no no no everything all the
time bring in everybody in fact you know
it was a deliberate political strategy
led by Ted Kennedy and others in this
country to change the the voting
demographics of the country to more
align with his politics and and I I
think it hasn't always been that and
that's not the only thing that was at
play there's also a huge economic aspect
which is when when your culture isn't
having babies at a replacement rate or
at a growing rate you have to bring in
immigrants in order to do certain jobs
especially in times of prosperity
there's other you Refugee concerns but
essentially the bad idea is that that
every culture is the same and therefore
no matter who we let into our country
our culture will remain our culture and
that that is a bad idea that kills
Nations and so you look around the world
right now and you see well it turns out
50 years into this experiment that all
cultures are not the same and that if
you bring in too many people from
certain cultures at a rate in which the
soup can't can't uh uh consume the
ingredient you start changing the taste
of the soup you start changing your
culture into their culture and people
are rightly pushing back against that I
don't think that they're always pushing
back against it in the right way but it
is right to push back against it and the
real question for the West is is it too
late you know when the when the number
one baby name in Britain is Muhammad you
you've gone a long way down this road
and what are you going to do about it
and I worry that what's ahead in the
next 20 years in the world is going to
be an incredibly dark time as the West
either goes
through death death gasps or course
corrects and either one of those is
likely to be painful uh and I'm likely
to disagree with a lot of the actions
taken by people who with uh who I think
did accurately diagnose the problem I
think one of the one of the challenges
particularly in the sort of emerging
right-wing movements around the world
today is that a lot of people are
accurately diagnosing the problem but
their prescription is the incorrect
prescription and that happens when you
push people who are who have not been
thinking about issues for a long time to
their breaking point you can't expect
that they're going to have the right
answer but they are going to be pretty
uh acutely aware that there's a problem
and I think that's part of what we're
seeing like like Conor McGregor burning
down shops and looting is a bad
reaction but an but but the outrage is
understandable 100% I want to read this
and a Vinnie I want to come to you I'm
going to read this tweet because this is
the one I miss and then I'm I'm going so
Leo varar this is a day of enormous joy
and relief for Emily hand and her family
an innocent child who was lost key word
lost lost has now been found and
returned and we breathe a massive sigh
of relief our prayers have been answered
by the way readers added context Emily
was not lost she was abducted by
terrorist from Hamas Conor McGregor she
was abducted by an evil terrorist
organization what is with you and your
government and your paid for media
Affiliates constantly downplaying
attempting to repress horrific Act that
happened to Children you are a disgrace
the day after a stabbing of children in
Ireland not one paper had it on their
front cover we will not forget I mean
look if there's anything about this guy
he knows how to fight but this guy knows
how to fight with his fist and his legs
but with his body but he also knows how
to fight with his mouth which is rare to
find Vinnie go ahead and the and it's
funny that the Irish government is going
after people who are complaining about
the problem instead of going after the
actual problem itself and by the way 75%
of people in Ireland think that this is
a problem they all think like how Connor
is thinking but uh let's let's think
about it this guy that attacked it was
an Algerian migrant he stabbed these
kids outside of a school p and uh he was
supposed to be deported 20 years ago but
the government let him stay gave him a
passport and citizenship he was also
caught with a knife earlier in the year
and guess what they let him go they just
let him go so you have to ask why all
these things are happening right p and
then and then there's bills that are
being put in place right now that are
pretty jacked up uh is it okay if he
shows his Pat Senator Pauline O'Reilly
was speaking about Ireland's hate speech
bill you know what I mean Jeremy because
they're going after these people I'll
have Rob play it and then I'll tell you
what this bill actually has and no
wonder why the people are pissed off
this is uh Senator Pauline Oy from
Ireland think about it all law all
legislation is about the Restriction of
Freedom that's exactly what we're doing
here is we are restricting freedom but
we're doing it for the common good you
will see throughout our constitution yes
you have rights but they are restricted
for the common good everything needs to
be Balan with the government I'm here to
help if your views on other people's
identities go to make their lives you
can stop that she's a very pleasant
Tyrant yeah yeah exactly she's sweet
she's not she actually you know when
somebody wears a necklace I trust them
but people don't realize how extreme
this bill this hate speech bill that
they're trying to do Jeremy you can get
up to 12 months in prison for refusing
to give your password to your device if
suspected of committing a hate speech if
they think you were being hateful you
have to give them your passcode of your
phone and all your social media or else
you go to uh prison for for 12 months
and I I I respect Connor Pat because he
is a true patriot think about it he's
worth hundreds of millions of dollars he
knows he's out there right he has an
amazing life amazing family I mean he he
himself he's pumping out kids left right
he's saving the Ireland's blood line
forever but um he could have stayed
quiet Pat he does why why did why do he
need to talk he knows once he went
public with his opinion that especially
going against the left's narrative that
they tried to destroy him and think
about it pat you remember a couple
months ago I started losing faith Jeremy
I was like hope and we had we had a
conversation I was sitting right where
you were sitting it's like you have to
keep hope and and he literally woke me
up and I and I turned my my mindset cuz
look what's happening in the world it
started with Trump Argentina elects
Malay the Netherlands elected uh gear
wielders the people in Spain are in the
street they're protesting by the
hundreds of thousands Elon bu Twitter he
you know let us speak our minds and now
Connor's hinting for running for office
I'm regaining that hope and that Faith
because it seems like the left keeps
getting left and more left and more left
but the people are actually speaking and
there is a chance for us because I'm
seeing it happen right in front of our
faces you you know you know what is
crazy while he's showing this clip the
clip that to me is the most shocking and
Rob I texted it to you if you can play
the clip from uh Poland the position he
takes while they're talking about uh uh
uh refugees go and play this clip this
never gets old go for it how many
refugees has Poland
taken zero and you're proud of that if
you are asking me if you're if you are
asking me about Muslim uh Muslims
illegal immigration none not even one
will come to Poland not even one if it's
illegal we we to over 2 million
ukrainians who are working who are
peaceful in Poland we will not receive
even one Muslim because this is what we
promised but I asked not about illegal
immigrants I asked about refugees and
Jun junker the commission President says
that you're racist you sound proud of
the fact that you haven't taken any
refugees of course because this is what
our people expecting from our government
that's number one this is why our
government was elected
but this is why Poland is so safe this
is the the the reason why we had not
even one terrorist attack look at the
streets in Poland and we can be called
populists nationalists racists I don't
care I care about my family and about my
country the the backbone is what you got
to respect what's your reaction when you
see this stuff happening well yeah you
know there's there's uh two countries in
Europe Poland and Hungary where they're
not abiding this and they're safe
countries you know I I don't know time
will tell if people like Victor orbon
are uh are have dictatorial Tendencies
certainly they have autocratic
Tendencies Benjamin Netanyahu has uh
autocratic Tendencies and time will tell
you know again power wealth and fame are
corrosive you will will the systems that
are in place in those countries and the
character of those men be able to
constrain in some way those worse the
the worst things that can happen in
those situations I certainly hope so but
on the other side in in the the more
what we might call the more democratic
countries the more liberal democracies
uh like America Britain France we're
losing our national identity and not
just our national identity but in the
name of radical individualism we're
losing individual identity too because
your daughter can actually lose
connection to the part of her identity
that is girl and your son can lose uh
part of his identity that is boy and
we're losing our ability to say that our
countries represent something good that
our cultures despite their flaws
represent something good in the world
and maybe even the best thing that's
ever been represented in the world and
so yes it is again maybe not all the
prescriptions are correct but you're
seeing absolutely the right diagnosis uh
by the former polish prime minister and
the current uh prime minister of Hungary
and and other G wers and others who are
coming up and hopefully Conor McGregor
too I hope so by by the way it's going
to be very if if he becomes a p oh my
God if he does it'll be the most
entertaining everybody worldwide is
going to want to go visit Ireland can
you imagine that where you going for
vacation I'm going over there they
shouldn't have debates they should have
a weighin be the greatest political EV
oh my God can you see foreign leaders
coming up here welcome to Ireland yeah
you know tomorrow tomorrow we debate but
first today we cuz you know somebody
would say something PNY be like what the
fu yeah what are you talking about F out
of here no he would be like okay today
we're going to open up the uh prayer
with proper 12 drink
everybody U okay so uh next couple
stores before we wrap up here so
Argentina mle says shutting down Central
Bank nonan
negotiable a Reuters story so here we go
uh this is on what page is it on Rob is
it three or four mle is on five okay
here we go uh let me see there you go
Argentina President elect Javier mle has
strongly reiterated his commitment to
closing the country's Central Bank
emphasizing that it is non-negotiable
matter this statement was made in
response to circulating rumor and lines
with M's campaign promising of enacting
substantial reforms and a shift from the
initial plan of appointing a close Ally
Economist Osvaldo gordano from the
central Cordoba region will lead
Argentina Social Security Administration
anets a critical institution given mle's
intention to reduce State spending and
subsidies additionally horio Marin a
private executive in the energy sector
has been officially named as the
incoming chief of the state Oil Company
ypf
Tom well he he's
basically Argentina's had what was it
150% inflation over 12 months and then
before that 80% so the last 3 years in
Argentina had been nothing short of
horrific and the people are ready for
that and he sees the manipulation of the
you know of the central banks all all
throughout the West Argentina is in the
west uh barely with the economy and and
things sliding and he's come out and
he's basically said listen I'm going to
break the back of inflation I'm going to
do this and we're going to stop the
manipulation of the Central Bank he's
even go so far to say that in a pin
he would petition for the US dollar to
be the
currency and by the way that's not
unusual there are there are dollar
proxies all around the world and I I
think he has spoken up for what exactly
what the people wanted and he's saying
we're going to pay for it by closing
government offices that are what do it
call it the decadence of a of um
Argentina the um meaning when he says
decadent he's been talking about all the
excessive spending on the backs of
people and guess what folks have had
enough and against a clear backdrop they
voted him in and he is sticking sticking
to it um about not having a central bank
that cow toow to other countries or that
is manipulating the currency I'll say
this I've I've spent much of the last
six months living in Hungary making our
our show the pin dragon cycle uh and
it's been a remarkable experience you're
you're in a country that is pushing back
against the sort of invogue excesses of
liberalism you're in a country that is
re uh
refacing sort of uh uh modernist uh
brutalist architecture from the Soviet
Union or or even corporatist
architecture with facades to make it
feel at home in the sort of Victorian
era 18th 1800s era uh style of the city
they're they're positively affirming
their Christianity they're positively
affirming their history they're
positively affirming uh their uh their
values and it's it's refreshing because
my entire life we've been apologizing
for our values my entire life we've been
saying that there is no value in the
past my entire life we've been saying
that the only future is a future that is
sort of culturally neutral and that is a
great failed experiment so my my great
hope is that these movements that are
happening uh in in Argentina in Poland
and in Hungary and perhaps Now in
Ireland and
elsewhere my great hope is that while
mistakes are going to be made while
there's going to be fumbles while people
are going to take the wrong step the the
D the pro the prescription will not
always be right that we find our way
back uh to a world where we can all have
pride in in the best parts of our
culture and build a better future you
know there there's a tendency in
conservatism to be very pessimistic to
think that all the best days are behind
I don't think our that the best days of
the world are behind I hope not because
every day in the past had huge problems
I think that as an entrepreneur our job
is to find problems and solve them you
don't do that as I said at the beginning
you don't do that by throwing out your
tradition you do it by taking everything
that was great using that as a firm
foundation and attacking problems uh in
a way that incentivizes success and so
you know my my time in in Hungary has
has uh really helped to clarify for me
what I think is a good pathway forward
again not a complete recommendation of
their political path which I which I
think in some ways is fraught but so is
our political path Frau and so we we
have to we have to find that Better Way
Forward
and one great way to do it that you're
seeing happen down in Argentina is by
actually bringing back economic
incentive and one of the great every
problem we've talked about today is a
place where we have divorced the success
of a movement the success of a
philosophy the success of a company from
actual economic incentives from actually
having to serve the needs that actually
exist in the marketplace and that's a
you know it's not the only answer but
it's an it's an incredible part of the
answer well you got to give M credit
credit because even uh just for the
short stint that people have been
following him he's also teaching people
Spanish now everybody knows what AA
means it means out so AA you know he's a
legendary teacher from Argentina now the
leader and uh is up to a bunch of
different crazy things Jeremy it's been
great having you on Rob can we make sure
we put the link again below for people
to go watch lady Ballers this is going
to Premiere this Friday December 1st on
daily wire uh plus you can watch it can
you buy the movie or do you have to
subscribe to watch the movie how does
that work subscribers only out of the
gate okay there you go so subscribers
out of the gate put the link below go
subscribe support the organization lady
Ballers and uh CEO of daily wire Jeremy
Bourne great having you on this was
great fantastic yes absolutely take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye